skyrock et bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur rt france alors les
protagonistes de la crise libyenne
doivent se rencontrer le 5 octobre
prochain à genève sous l'égide des
nations-unies pour choisir un nouvel
exécutif destiné à diriger la transition
dans le pays est ce que vous êtes
optimiste quant à l'avenir de la libye
oui pour une fois je suis optimiste car
le principal obstacle à un accord
politique en libye était monsieur sa
rage monsieur s'arrache qui est l'homme
nommé parle par l'onu qui a couvert tous
les trafics de migrants d'esclaves tous
les trafics d'armes etc etc a permis à
monsieur erdogan est à quatorze mille
miliciens syrien islamistes de venir
combattre en libye pour sauver tripoli
mais c'est sa rage est le principal
responsable de l'absence d'accord
politique en libye depuis cinq ans donc
il 120 c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour la libye pour le peuple libyen et
pour la paix et justement la turquie a
accueilli 7 cette démission un petit peu
de façon mitigée mais elle a tout de
même affirmé qu'elle continuera de
soutenir le gène a même si sa large part
bien sûr l'homme fort actuellement de
tripoli c'est monsieur bachaga le mini
ses intérieurs ministre de la défense le
seul qui a une prise directe sur les
milices islamistes de tripoli et qu'il
peut les amener à composer avec les
représentants du maréchal haftar donc je
pense que entre monsieur à guînes hassan
et le président de l'assemblée nationale
libyenne
monsieur bachagha et le maraîcher nafta
nous sommes en route pour un accord
politique et la voie diplomatique va
enfin permettre d'arriver à supprimer ce
conflit qui dure depuis neuf années
aujourd'hui telle est la position
aujourd'hui marie sala fartage l
maréchal star n'a pas pu prendre tripoli
puisqu'il souhaitait faire pour
réunifier la libye la pacifier la
sécuriser à cause de l'intervention de
monsieur erdogan au monsieur erdogan
apparemment a compris que la france
plaisante et bah quand est-ce qu'on
tenait le président macron disaient
qu'ils allaient s'opposer à monsieur
erdogan fermement avec force et donc
après l'exemple de ce qui s'est passé
avec la grèce
monsieur erdogan a compris que la france
était prête à intervenir militairement
pour aider la grèce président l'air
dogan a reculé
il a rangé son bateau de fourrage il a
rangé ses bateaux de guerre et en libye
va se passer exactement la même chose à
savoir que la la la turquie n'a rien à
faire en libye à la verse ce que déclare
monsieur erdogan et son ministre de la
défense
la turquie n'a rien à faire en libye
elle est un fauteur de guerre
un monsieur erdogan est le parrain de
l'international des frères musulmans
ils sont les principaux groupes
islamistes radicaux et donc il faut
absolument qu'il se retire de 2 alors le
problème de la négociation serait
d'abord de mettre d'accord les libye
entre eux c'est quand même l'essentiel
d'arriver à définir un nouveau conseil
présidentiel un nouveau gouvernement
d'union nationale avec un nouveau
premier ministre
de prévoir aussi la répartition de la
manne pétrolière entre la cyrénaïque la
tripolitaine et le faisan est d'arriver
à lancer un processus démocratique
permettant dans le délai d'un an et il
faut bien cela à organiser des élections
qui me permettront enfin d'avoir à
pouvoir politique légitime en libye ce
qui est pas le cas aujourd'hui puisque
la seule institution élu de ce pays
depuis 2014 et l'assemblée nationale qui
est à tobrouk
justement concernant le pétrole là
monsieur à ce quartier on sait que la
trêve a permis une reprise de l'activité
pétrolière qu'est ce que ça représente
pour la libye ça représente l'essentiel
en termes de revenus fiscaux
il faut savoir que au moment de la
guerre de 2011
la libye produisait près 2 1 million 200
mille barils jour
donc vous voyez la manne pétrolière que
cela peut représenter même si le baril
aujourd'hui est un prix est très
inférieur à ce qu'il était à l'époque
mais l'or
que lorsque le maréchal haftar a pris le
contrôle de la rhk pétroliers hilary
l'art il a permis à la production de
revenir à son niveau de 2011 juste avant
la taxe sur tripoli la production
pétrolière libyenne était revenu à un
niveau très important donc le problème
c'est que cet argent partez grâce à
l'onu à tripoli à la banque centrale que
la banque centrale donner cet argent à
monsieur sa rage et que ça servait à
financer les milices islamistes
dernièrement que très rapidement
dernière question monsieur je voudrais
juste vous posez deux dernières
questions très rapidement est ce que
finalement on peut dire tout de même que
ces derniers développements reste
tributaire d ingérence des pays
étrangers
et je parle là pour les deux camps que
ça soit la turquie et le qatar qui
soutiennent sa loge où l'egypte et la
russie qui se range du côté de juan
barahona
tout à fait mais je crois que à partir
du moment où un accord politique inter
libyen
il n'y aura plus d'un dur d'ingérence
étrangère peut-être que on donnera une
base navale à la turquie une base navale
à la russie sont les remercier de leurs
interventions chaque camp mais en dehors
de cela il n'y aura plus de l'ingérence
étrangère je ne pense pas en tout cas
militaire il pourrait y avoir des
ingérences économique des ingérences
industriel mais plus militaire
merci beaucoup michel a ajouté je
voudrais juste raison que le président
macron tente d'organiser une réunion à
paris un côté de celle de genève entre
les principaux protagonistes et dans les
jours qui viennent donc nous allons voir
si cela réussit ou pas mais nous sommes
en chômage pour la paix en libye
enfin merci beaucoup michel blanquer
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien député
européen et consultant sur le moins 9